heythe UI just calling to make sure
everything's a-okay yeah Andrew you call
five minutes ago I'm fine
someone's coming for the AFC South what
I was only heard for three years okay do
you I go deep the next part is very
important they're gonna take the
decision Oh golly
don't know who you are I don't know what
you want but I'm Andrew hello I have a
very particular set of skills skills
have acquired over almost half a career
skills like accuracy good
decision-making and recommending the
perfect flow sorry for evading you good
try though so close skills that make me
a nightmare for people like you and I'm
sorry about that I need to be focused so
we all play our best he's gonna dogs our
data if you let the AFC South go now
that'll be the end of it oh boy what
kind of a person would hang out in a
gross place like this oh hello mr. say
Andrew man I like you man but if you
don't I will look for you I will find
you you silly goose now absolutely
destroy him
oh I can tell he's threatening us or not
hey guys you forget how mobile he is get
him
I have cover now
[Music]
so slow this channel wash wiper sauce I
gotta go